-The game works
exactly like "Pictionary"
except the person who is drawing
will be wearing one of these
virtual-reality headsets
and drawing in 3-D space using
a program called Tilt Brush.
We'll be able
to see their point of view
on the big screen behind us.
I will go first. You guys
can all take your seats.
-Okay.
-Here we go.
All right, ready?
-Oh, gosh, okay.
-Ready, partner?
-I'm ready.
-Cool. Give me a number.
What should I choose?
[ Audience shouting ]
All right. Here we go.
Three it is.
One person yelled three.
All right.
All right, here we go.
Three. Okay.
So the subject is --
It's a phrase.
-Okay.
-Where are you? Okay, good.
-I'm here.
-Ready?
-Yeah.
-Here we go. Um...
-Okay. A duck.
What? What? A shoe. Uh, wait.
It's a mustache!
It's lips. Lips.
Kylie Lip Kit, no?
Um, uh, oh, Rolling Stones.
-Eh.
-No.
Your tongue. No. No.
Oh, no. Okay, okay.
You're -- It's a tornado.
-Unh! Unh!
-It's a -- It's a --
Tornado -- Ehh!
Tor-- I don't know!
-Ahh!
Okay. Okay. Word vomit?
[ Cymbal crash ]
[ Laughs ] Okay.
Oh, wow.
Now I'm all turned around.
-No. Here we go.
-Okay. It's okay. We got this.
Tongue.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, man!
[ Fog horn ]
-I didn't know what else to do.
Tongue twister.
-Oh.
-Tongue twister.
-Shoot. Sorry.
-I let America down.
All right. Well --
Lil Wayne,
you are up next, buddy.
-Oh, man.
-Of course. You lucked out.
-All right.
-All right, here you go, bud.
-We got this.
-Choose the number
before you put it on your head.
Then you got to hold this thing
in your left hand.
-Okay, let me choose one.
-I mean, your right hand.
-Number five is cool?
-Five is good.
-Five is cool?
-That's my favorite number.
-My partner says
number five is cool.
-All right. This is good.
-All right.
-Wait. Did I choose it yet?
-No, no. You have to read it.
[ Laughter ]
You can't guess
what the thing is.
-Oh, man, he's killing it.
-You know, it makes it easier
if you know what
you're drawing, yeah.
-How are you going to do that?
[ Laughter ]
-Let me see what you got.
Oh, no.
-Okay.
-No, I don't know.
-All right.
I got you. I got you.
-Do I have to press anything?
-Yeah, like,
a little trigger there.
-The trigger?
All right. All right.
-What's -- What's the category?
-The category.
-What -- How do I --
-It's a food?
-Food.
-A food.
-Yes.
-Okay.
-All right, let me know
when we're ready.
-All right.
-You ready?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-You have to say something.
-Yeah, we're ready.
-Oh, ready, ready.
-Okay. Okay.
-All right, cool.
-Okay.
-Oh, gosh.
-Um, peanuts.
Um, uh -- Really? No.
-Close.
-Coke? Nut.
Um, um...
Uh, um...
Wow. Edamame.
Popcorn! Popcorn.
-Really?
-Um -- Ooh.
Uh, oh.
Uh, steamy popcorn?
Um, pop --
[ Laughter ]
Wait. What?
Oh, popcorn shrimp!
-Oh, my gosh!
♪♪
-How did you get that?!
How in the world?!
-How did that happen?
-How did you know
that was a shrimp?!
-That was amazing.
-That was not a shrimp!
That was not --
That was not a shrimp at all.
That was a --
-It was steamy popcorn.
-That was a sperm or something.
I don't know what that was.
Lana, you're up. Here we go.
Come on.
-It's okay. There's still hope.
-Let's go.
There's hope. We got this.
-There's redeeming -- Okay.
-Oh, my God. All right.
-What number should we do?
Okay. We're going to do eight.
-All right.
-Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
I can do this.
Okay. Here we go.
-Oh, no. Sorry.
You got to put this on.
You can't hold it on your head.
Yeah, you got to put this --
-Okay.
Ah. Okay. Whoa!
-Oh, yes, I told you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-No. Okay. Okay.
-And pull that trigger
when you're ready to draw.
-Okay. It's a restaurant.
-It's a restaurant?
-Yeah.
-Applebee's?
-No, I haven't started.
-Oh, sorry.
-You got this.
-Okay.
Okay. [ Laughs ]
Come on!
-Ugh.
-Ahh! Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, my God. Wait. Uh...
-Oh, my God!
-Okay.
-All right.
-I'm scared.
-Where are you going?
[ Laughter ]
Oh! Taco Bell!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's how you do it.
That is how you do Taco Bell.
-Ugh! I did it!
-Not bad!
Lana, well done.
Claire, it's your turn.
-All right,
all right, all right.
Um, okay.
What?
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know what it is.
-That's so mean.
-I didn't do it.
-That is so mean.
-You're the one that choose
seven. I'm not being mean.
All right, no. [ Laughs ]
-Oh, my gosh. Okay.
It's an object.
-Okay.
-Can you do, like, second word?
-I don't know what that means
but, yeah, sure.
"Can I do second word?" Yeah.
-I don't know.
All right. Let's see.
Okay. Here we go.
All right.
-It's an object.
-Um. Ehh. Uh.
Uhh, oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
-Dog? Dog?
-No.
Um, uh, like --
Um, okay. Uh.
-That's not bad.
-Holy cow.
-Uh, well, kinda. No.
-A bull? Is that --
-Yes! Yes, yes.
Okay, so --
-It's an object.
-Okay. Yeah, so then --
Um...
[ Laughter ]
-Bull [bleep]?
-Um. Oh, my gosh. Uh.
-This is good. This is good.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Fog horn ]
-I don't know.
-It was a mechanical bull.
-Ohh.
[ Laughter ]
-That is exactly what that was.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's so hard!
-That was perfect.
It was perfect. All right.
It's time for the final round.
It's going to be --
-No.
-Oh, my God.
-All right.
-...seen a virtual
mechanical bull before.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, no.
-All right.
Here's the showdown.
Lil Wayne, you will draw this.
If Claire guesses the clue
first, then you guys win.
If Lana or I get it,
then we win.
-Okay.
-Here we go. All right. Ready?
All right, it's up to you.
You can pick a clue. Which one?
-I have to pick the number?
-All right.
-Yeah.
Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
-I guess the audience
just saw what the word was.
-What's the category
or whatever?
It's like --
-It's a person.
-Person. All right.
-Okay. Here we go.
-Okay.
-All right. Let me know
when you're ready.
-All right.
-You ready?
-Yep. Person.
Uh. Ronald McDonald.
Um, uh, Trump. Um...
-What?
-Cousin Itt!
-Uh. Tina Turner?
I don't know.
-Questlove!
-What?
-Well, I thought maybe
with the hair.
His hair. Who has an afro?
-What?
-One?
-Okay. Is it Questlove?
-Diana Ross.
-No, no, no. Clearly not.
-Um, uh.
-Okay.
-Um...
-Uh...
-What?!
-Oh.
-Are they smoking something?
-He's smoking.
-They're smoking something.
-The pot. The marijuana.
-They're smoking pot.
-Okay.
-Who has an afro and spokes pot?
[ Buzzer ]
-Pothead!
-It's Harry Potter!
-Harry Potter?!
-Harry potter!
That's so good!
That's amazing!
Oh, my God!
-Oh, my God.
♪♪
-That's incredible!
-He wins, he wins, he wins.
The winner, Lil Wayne!
That was awesome.
That was awesome. You win.
Oh, my God.
-That was amazing.
-My thanks to Claire Danes.
Lana Condor, Lil Wayne.
The champions.
You are the champs.